what was the gift in the curse because
we always hear about like signing to
other artists and i do think boozy
doesn't get enough
respect as a ceo you know his label is
doing its thing but what was the gift in
the curse being assigned to another
artist
uh i say the uh
me it really would i feel like it's all
on the artist you know what i'm saying
it's out on order like
it's on it's it's about how hard it is
case by case situation
yeah you know what i'm saying because
it's like somebody can sign you to
they label you could be the biggest
artist in the world you know what i'm
saying
and but
what you gonna do once you get signed
you know i think that's where a lot of
people make the mistake is they sign
and then they're like okay then they
just wait on on on them
and that's what as opposed to like nah
now you gotta roll your [ __ ] sleeves
up so you'll get down and really get to
work
yeah because you don't don't you can't
depend on nobody for your own [ __ ] ever
control your own destination and most of
the time the artists you know they had
they
own stuff going on too so it's like they
can't they probably could be focused on
you but they gonna always be focusing on
you so the time that they not
they probably be working on the album or
they probably got some personal stuff
going on
that they can't really give all their
time to you so you gotta
roll up your sleeves and turn up so that
was the thing that was different from me
like
when i got in some things in your own
hands yeah like you know i took that
cosine and
ran ran once and did my thing so
like if you ain't really got that in you
then you probably just go
you know i'm saying just be on beyond
and i'm like i won't really
around boost it like i used to be around
boosted
and i still be around them but i just
went like around them every day like i
used to go do my
own stuff you know as i make my own
name for myself and then came back like
yeah you know what i'm saying talk about
what you've learned from boozy because
we were talking earlier
and i was like you were told me you were
shooting a video in l.a and i was like
well here's the artist and you were like
you know somebody who just bagged you
out yeah yeah and um
you know i know boozy whatever city he's
in yeah
he's pull up have your money right and
you get in the verse and you were saying
that you kind of do something similar
and i
you know i think that there's a couple
of ways to look at that i think some
people might be like
you might water down your value but at
the same time like you're an independent
artist
and you don't know if this is as good as
it's gonna get yeah yeah so you might as
well get every bag you can right now
yeah i mean like i said i used to worry
about like
yeah booster kind of taught me that you
know what i'm saying i used to worry
about
how it would look you know what i'm
saying if i posted this
i posted that but i mean you gotta look
at it like
people gonna talk regardless you know
what i'm saying like
and then and and my point of view is
like
yeah people gonna talk with girls so you
might as well get it why because when
it's over with yeah
once you're run over with you know you
know what i'm saying
like right like get every dollar you can
off your name
while it's hot you know what i'm saying
because when it's not hot
people ain't gonna care people ain't
gonna care what you guess what if i go
do
if i go post i'm doing features right
now and like the next week
i posted i made 100k out featured get
what everybody said
get what everybody's saying you know
what i'm saying everybody you know said
co-signing that like people want to do
that you know what i'm saying so
it ain't no bad thing but like people
gonna talk regardless man get get your
coins especially if you put in all these
years of work
i saw a quote today was like you know
saying
it probably take me 30 minutes to do a
job right now
and make all this money but the years
and years that i put in before that you
ain't see that you know what i'm saying
so you paying me for them years you feel
you ain't paying me for this 30 minutes
i came to the studio you paying
me for all these everything to get that
and then plus like
like i said bro you know what i'm saying
i'm going to eat i know people do
way more but like i said i screamed 30
million
screens every two months you know what
i'm saying so i
i deserve it you feel me so